in the last video we saw that if we
started with a massive star about 9 to
20 times the mass of the sun
and when it finally matures the remnant
of the star is roughly or that remnant
core of the star is roughly one and a
half to three times the solar mass or
the mass of the sun then this remnant
right here and let me just be clear this
9 to 20 times is the mass of that star
when it's in its when it's in its main
sequence this one and a half to three
times is the mass once it's shed off a
lot of the
i guess outer material of the star and
this is really the mass of the remnant
of the star kind of the core of the star
but at that remnant once it stops fusing
once it stops having outward pressure
once it has enough
density this we saw in the last video
will cause a supernova it will cause a
shock wave to move out through the rest
of the material and essentially cause it
to blow up and this will condense
this will condense into a neutron star
into a neutron star now in this video
what i want to talk about is what if
we're starting with a star that has a
mass more than this is give or take we
don't know the actual firm boundaries
here but what if we have a a star what
if we have a star that is more than 20
times the mass of the sun and this is
kind of the original mass before the
star burns itself out or when when that
star has kind of reached this old age
once it has that iron core it has more
than so i could say the remnant
the remnant
the dense remnant has more than three to
four times
the mass of the sun and remember it's
going to have through more than three
it's going to have three to four times
the mass of sun it's going to be far
denser it's just going to be a core it's
going to be an iron nickel core that's
no longer fusing so what happens to
these stars so it turns out that these
are so massive that even even the
neutron degeneracy pressure will not be
enough to keep the mass from imploding
and these stars all of the mass in these
stars will just keep imploding so in the
neutron so we imagine the first and kind
of sun-like stars things would collapse
into
white dwarfs and maybe i should draw
that in white
so they would collapse into white dwarfs
no that's not white either
there you go they would collapse into
white dwarfs eventually so this is a
white dwarf
white
dwarf and here the pressure that's
keeping this from collapsing further is
electron degeneracy pressure the atoms
are squeezed so much that the electrons
are essentially keeping them from
squeezing anymore but if the pressure
gets large enough then you have the
neutron star so you have even more mass
and even a smaller and i'm not drawing
this to scale neutron stars are tiny
white draw white dwarf stars are on the
scale of an earth-like planet neutron
stars we learned in the last video are
on the scale of a city so there's a
super dense super tiny and this has more
mass than this over here in fact maybe
you'll actually just draw it as a dot
just so you have a sense of how dense it
is it's really just like one big atomic
nucleus or
well it's still small but it's the size
of a city it's like a nucleus the size
of a city but this right here is a
neutron star
neutron star and what's unintuitive
about what i'm drawing is each of these
smaller things have more mass this
overcame the electron degeneracy
pressure to collapse even further but if
the mass is large enough and this is
what we're talking about in this video
even the neutron degeneracy power will
pressure will not be able to keep that
mass from collapsing and there's even
theoretical a quark stars where the
quark degeneracy pressure but if you get
even beyond that then it all collapses
into into a single
point and i'm simplifying here but
it collapses into a single point of
infinite density
infinite
mass
density
and this
this is really the mass of a black hole
and i'm calling it the mass of a black
hole because there's different ways how
you can view where a black hole starts
and ends or what exactly is the black
hole
so this is all the mass all
the mass
of
the black hole
of the black or we could say of the
original star
so when we're talking about that remnant
being three to four times three to four
solar masses all of that mass is now
being contained well not all of it some
of it was released as energy during the
supernova and that was also true of the
neutron star but most of that mass is
now being contained in this infinitely
small point
and you'll hear physicists and math
mathematicians talk about singularities
singularities and singularities are
really points and even in mathematics
where everything breaks down where
nothing starts to make sense anymore
where the where where the the
mathematical equations don't give you a
defined answer and this is a singularity
because you have you have a ton of mass
in an infinitely small space you
essentially have an infinite density
right here and and this is hard to
visualize but you have kind of an
infinite curvature and space time right
here and i can't visualize that so maybe
we'll think about that in more videos
but the reason why i said
that it's it's there's different ways to
think about where a black hole is or
where it starts and ends is that this is
where the mass is so and if there's any
other mass that was over here would
obviously be attracted to this mass and
then become part of that singularity
would add to that mass that that already
huge mass that's in an infinitely small
point in space but the reason why the
boundaries hard to define is because
there's some point at which there's some
pointed space around that singularity at
which no matter what that thing is no
matter how much energy that thing has it
will not be able to ex it will not be
able to escape the gravitational
influence of the black hole of that
ultra dense mass so even if it was even
if it was electromagnetic radiation even
if it was light and even if it's light
that's that's shown away from the mass
it will eventually have to go back it
will not be able to escape the
gravitational influence and so the
boundary
the boundary
where if you're within that boundary
that's really a sphere so that boundary
around the singularity
and that boundary around singularity
where if you're within the boundary no
matter what you do no matter if you're
electromagnetic radiation you're still
going to you're never going to be able
to escape the black hole if you are
beyond that boundary you might be able
to escape the black hole so this guy
could escape this guy over here no
matter what he does is going to have to
go back into the black hole this
boundary right here is called the event
horizon
this right here is the event horizon
another word used in a lot of science
fiction movies and for good reason
because it's fascinating and we'll
actually learn in the in future videos
hopefully about hawking radiation we'll
see that that is not radiation from the
black hole itself it's it's the
byproduct of quantum effects that are
occurring at the event horizon but the
event horizon is just this it's this
kind of point in space or the sphere in
space or this boundary in space anything
closer than or within the event horizon
has to eventually end up in the
singularity contributing to that mass
anything on the outside has a chance of
escaping so what would a black hole look
like well not even light can escape from
it so it will be black
it will be black in in in the pure sense
it will not emit any type of radiation
from the black hole itself from with
from that mass and so here are some
here are some depictions i got from nasa
of black holes and so just to be clear
what's happening here what you're seeing
here is black that is not you can view
that as the black hole when people talk
about the black hole that's often what
they're talking about but there's
there's a point of infinite density at
the center of this of this black sphere
right here and what you see is that
black sphere that really is the boundary
of the event horizon
so this right here is the boundary of
the event
horizon and what we're seeing right here
is the accretion disk around the black
hole as as all of this matter gets
closer and closer to it it's being
squeezed more and more it's moving
faster and faster and getting hotter and
hotter and that's why the way this arch
is depicted looks like this stuff over
here is redder and hotter than the stuff
further out it's just accelerating as it
approaches that event horizon once it
approaches that once it's in the event
horizon we cannot even see the light
that is emitting even though it would be
you know starting to become unbelievably
energetic here's some other pictures
this is a this is a picture of a star
being ripped apart not a picture there's
actually an artist's depiction all of
these are artist depictions we never
were able to get uh such good pictures
of of actual action occurring near black
holes these are artist depiction but
this is a star being ripped apart by a
black hole so this this star is getting
pretty close pretty close to this black
hole already out here very where the
star is it's very strong gravitational
attraction so any mass any that's being
emitted from the star in that direction
is slowly being pulled into the black
hole so the star is kind of being ripped
apart by the black hole this is maybe a
better depiction of it this is the star
at first and once it gets under once it
becomes under the influence of of the
black hole's gravitation it starts to
kind of elongate and gets ripped apart
and its matter goes starts spiraling in
closer and closer to that black hole and
then once it's in the event horizon we
won't even see it anymore because even
the light from that from that matter
that it intensely hot can matter that's
entering into the black hole cannot even
escape the black hole itself anyway
hopefully you found that interesting and
you know i want to be clear
we still don't understand a lot about
black holes in fact you know this whole
notion of a singularity
the fact that all the math and all the
theory breaks down at the singularity
is a pretty good sign that our theory
isn't complete because if our theory is
complete we would maybe get something a
little bit more sensical than just all
of our equations not making sense at
that infinitely dense point anyway
hopefully you found that interesting